nous avons été élus pour avoir des
résultats pour la population pour
assumer des responsabilités et à partir
du moment où il y à des facteurs de
blocage
1 je me dois de savoir quels sont ces
facteurs blocage d'où viennent les
blocages qui bloque
et ce sont ces ce 40 nm débattent ce
matin là j'ai demandé à marine et de
torpilles qui est chargé du
développement économique au sein de
l'exécutif comme je le suis moi au sein
de l'assemblée de m'expliquer pourquoi
le dossier du fonds jérémy je rappelle
que c'est un fonds qui a pour objet de
financer les petites et moyennes
entreprises et notamment les plus
petites
ceux qui n'ont pas de capitaux soit en
avec des prêts soit des prises de
participation mais dynamiser le tissu
économique qui n'entend qui ne trouve
pas avec les banques les réponses à ces
besoins et qui est très dynamique et
quitte le principal créateur d'emplois à
la martinique
et bien ce fonds jérémy aujourd'hui dont
nous avons voté la mise en place d
toujours pas mis en place
donc j'ai demandé à la conseillère
exécutif à l'exécutif à marinette tant
pis pourquoi est ce fonds n'était pas
mis en place et elle m'a expliqué qu'il
y avait des blocages parce que le
conseil exécutif chargé des fonds
européens miguel laventure n'avait pas
compris l'urgence de ce projet